we have this story
uh from sf gate
car break-ins in san francisco are
rampant will a 100 000 reward help you
know what i love about this let me let
me read they say on tuesday morning
mayor london breed announced a new
privately funded reward of up to a
hundred thousand dollars leading to the
arrest and conviction of individuals
involved in organized crime rings which
the mayor's office says fuels automobile
burglaries the reward is funded by
private by private donors in the
hospitality and tourism industry wow
press release the mayor's office did not
immediately return a request for more
information about these private donors
so um
san francisco has become this nightmare
dystopia of failed policy
oligarchs funding
uh reward bounties i have to i have to
imagine the hundred thousand dollars
could just go to like i don't know
hiring police
yeah i mean this is this is a disturbing
trend it's also rise of private security
in san francisco it's been very
prominent we're in a huge crisis of
morale with the police that's been there
ever since last summer
and it's resulting in greater homicides
and greater crime overall and
you know one of the interesting
questions i had when i was working on
san francisco was
because so much of what is justified in
san francisco in terms of open-air drug
use public defecation public camping
these things are defended as ways of not
blaming the victim
you know helping the victim so one
question is why would then do
progressive support policies that end up
creating so many more victims
and the answer it turns out is that
progressives are really focused on
saving the victims of the system
they're not so this is why you know 30
times more african-americans are killed
by civilians than by police officers so
why the disproportionate attention on
police killings
because those are killings by people
that are perceived as the system so
progressive you know the word
progressive really was a way to both
change move away from the word liberal
which was demonized in the late 1980s
it was also though a way to kind of
unite both the radical left and more
moderate liberals
but one of the things that it inherited
is this idea that really the only you
know that the system itself is evil and
corrupt and that we should only care and
make a big deal out of the victims of
that system and so you just see all
these efforts to basically do anything
other than do what needs to be done
which is restore confidence in our in
the institutions of civilization in the
institutions of the so-called system you
i guess
i don't know if
well i'll just ask you used to be i
guess a lefty leftist or liberal how
would you describe yourself yeah i would
have described myself as radical left uh
certainly in the 90s um i worked on and
now you're now you're far right of
course
i'm here aren't i yeah
i yeah i worked on um uh environmental
causes climate change i worked on you
know criminal justice issues in the
1990s there's some people in the comment
section saying that you are connected to
soros george soros is that true yeah i
worked for george soros's uh funded
organizations but also his foundation
itself the open society institute
how is that what was it impactful for
your kind of political ideology can you
speak to that a little bit because i'm
getting a lot of comments about that in
the comment section yeah so
well so you know we have to remember you
know you're coming out in the 1980s and
1990s were coming out of a big war on
drugs and a widely held view that we had
overreacted to things like crack and
that what we should have been doing is
drug treatment is mandating rehab rather
than sending guys off to the prisons for
decades and that's still mostly of you i
hold there was also other things going
on there was liberalization of opioid
pharmaceuticals because it was viewed as
we were under treating pain and then we
were also promoting the
decriminalization of marijuana which we
viewed as a relatively benign drug
particularly in comparison to alcohol
and cigarettes
and then also we were advocating for
providing clean needles to addicts
because of a way to stop hiv aids
transmissions
when i got out of that work around the
year 2000 my understanding was that we
were seeking to make drug rehabilitation
including work including compliant you
know
taking your psychiatric meds doing what
you need to do to live a healthy life
my understanding was that we were going
to continue to mandate those things as
an alternative to prison
what ended up happening
not in a single law but in a set of laws
and ballot initiatives is that we
basically just said
no you can we've decriminalized stealing
950 worth of items from walgreens we've
decriminalized three grams of hard drugs
that was in the same ballot initiative i
voted for it 62 percent of californians
voted for it prop 47 in the year 2014
but you put those two things together
decriminalizing three grams of fentanyl
and meth and stealing 950 worth of items
and you get
yes organized crime but crimes that are
being committed to feed people's
addictions you know one of the things
that really bugged me and i mentioned
this the other day but i talk about a
lot i hear it all the time from the
progressives there are more empty houses
than homeless people
having actually worked with
homeless uh shelters more than one uh
you learn a lot about why people are
homeless and it's not this fancy this
fantasy idea of people being like pardon
me sir i'm desperate for a place to live
it's actually people who are like get
away from me i want to be homeless and
they're drinking
and you try and you try and be nice
respectful you try to help people but a
lot of them you know outside of mental
illness there are people who are
literally like don't come near me or
else
yeah you got it i mean you basically
what happens is
in the 1980s you see multiple things
going on but basically you have a crack
epidemic which is really crack and
alcohol those are the two drugs that
would get paired a lot resulting in
homelessness meaning that people would
be um they would quit their jobs and
dedicate their day hours to their
addictions they would then disaffiliate
this is the academic word disaffiliation
they would basically become alienated
from friends and family who they had
stolen from or borrowed money from and
finally friends and family are like
you gotta leave they're kicking you out
so you basically that is how people
became
homeless
there was also then
de-institutionalization of our
psychiatric hospitals a lot of those
folks were dumped on the streets
so that was what was going on in the 80s
the radical left
really working with liberals um
basically said these people the problem
with these folks is that they don't have
housing and there was always a move for
socialized housing and and and basically
free public housing
so they literally invented this
propaganda word there's no other way to
say it homelessness itself is a
propaganda word designed to trick your
brain
into putting people with totally
different problems in the same category
including people with schizophrenia
people with a heroin problem and the
proverbial mother escaping an abusive
husband the mother escaping the abusive
husband who doesn't have a drug drug or
alcohol problem and is not mentally ill
we do a great job of helping that woman
there's that's not a problem okay
the the person with schizophrenia and
the person with with an addiction
those folks on the street that's a huge
problem not just both for them it's
immoral the way we treat them but also
it's it degrades the fabric of a city do
you think do you think living in san
francisco led to kind of a political
transition for you and are there any
kind of policies you advocated for under
the kind of soros that were influenced
that you kind of regret now
great question so i mean one thing is
there's certain there's certainly
i have become more conservative around
drugs and alcohol um i still support the
decriminalization of marijuana but i
would like to see it more heavily
regulated i still support alcohol being
legal but i
i think amount i actually come to see
things like not being able to buy at the
grocery store not going to buy on sunday
things that restrict
uh
consumption i think is is good um
you know psychedelics i worry that we're
just just diving headlong into basically
decriminalizing psychedelics without any
thought about what the implications of
that are
you know i when in the 90s i still
remember very vividly being in
progressive non-profits it was global
exchange in san francisco brain force
action network we all hung out together
and the homeless advocates struck me as
it just struck me as bizarre because all
i always knew just because i was pretty
street savvy even in my 20s because i
had done a fair amount of just traveling
and i talked to people
i just knew that these folks were
addicts and that they were had mental
illness and so this sort of the kind of
emotional defense of the right of these
people to sleep on the sidewalks i
always sort of viewed as bizarre like it
never made any sense to me still to this
day you'll see progressives
high-profile youtubers posting things
like that's proof of the
do you know the dysfunctional nature of
capitalism and i'm like someone saying
they don't want to be in a building is
not anything to do with capitalism at
all well it's sad too i mean they're
these are often what they're they're
defending the right of psychotic people
in psychotic states whether from
underlying schizophrenia or from heavy
meth use it always manifests the same
way
defending you know we don't we don't let
grandma with dementia and alzheimer's
live on the street so why do we do that
with people in a psychotic state well
let's take their argument where they say
there are more empty houses than
homeless people do we just take a you
know 30 year old schizophrenic man put
him in a house and say have a nice day
what do you think would happen to that
person in that house if you just put
they have no food they have how they can
afford utilities how are they going to
maintain the building well what's going
to happen to it well we know i mean
we've actually been doing an ongoing
experiments on this question and then we
had a big one during covid because we
had to because they reduced the shelter
population and people in hotels
the hotel first of all a lot of people
died because there wasn't another user
with them to revive them with narcan
after they overdosed
it's multi-factorial obviously so
there's also we're also doing a fentanyl
epidemic which is um uh incredibly
deadly so first that happened i mean the
propaganda has been and this is the
propaganda coming from
the big foundations rockefeller but it
also comes from malcolm gladwell at the
new yorker and it also came from george
w bush in the in the in the early 2000s
which was just give people housing
that's the cure
the evidence was never there for any of
it um in fact it doesn't over harvard
just published a major study on this
over a 12-year period
those folks do not retain their housing
any better than anybody else does but it
doesn't do anything to address the
underlying causes of homelessness which
are mostly addiction untreated mental
illnesses there's a lot of political
commentators that directly point the
finger at individuals like george soros
when they got involved in local politics
appointing da's and implementing a lot
of these policies what's your kind of
train of thought with his involvement
with the the things that he called for
that he paid for that he kind of caused
in major cities
yeah i mean so george soros his
orientation is around um i would call
him a left libertarian and that is a
that is the cat that is left libertarian
would encompass kind of the anarchists
that the anarchist that took over
seattle for example which is something i
discussed in the book but it also
includes people like soros i i quote the
person who worked for source for a long
time somebody that i i knew pretty well
i've known for almost 25 years and he
said you know he goes george's view is
that people should if people want
something
they should have access to it you know
and so
it's a kind of that's a kind of
libertarian mentality you want heroin or
fentanyl well you should be able to buy
it like why should we restrict your
freedom so that's part of it but then
there's the the more
liberal or the more left part is also
this idea well those people are probably
victims too so there's two separate
conceptual universes that are being
married in this so it kind of goes you
want access to fentanyl and you're a
victim and therefore we should give you
whatever you want not just the needles
but a place to sleep and we should give
you medical care but we shouldn't do
anything to persuade you not to use
fentanyl or meth much less like enforce
laws against you because that would be
immoral because you're a victim yeah
that's a basic pictures a lot of the
da's in a lot of very important places
are directly backed by him he gives a
lot of money and this buys them a lot of
influence like in loudoun county uh a
county not far away from us where a big
story broke that some people literally
yeah some people are being censored a
few days ago the prosecutor tried to
give the father who was the victim in
this in this case prison sentence for
showing up at a school board meeting and
raising concerns about this and and this
prosecutor
had eight hundred sixty thousand dollars
given to him by soros pack uh his name
is bhuta benjari uh and and he's
literally implementing policy on the
local level in such a way where it's
extremely political extremely divisive a
lot of times very hardened criminals get
get off and a lot of people for
political crimes go to jail for very
hard sentences so that's why i was kind
of hinting and i kind of wanted to talk
to you about it because you seem to have
kind of experience in it but but a lot
of people are pointing to this as some
of the main reasons why there's such
urban decay happening all over the
united states and that's why i kind of
wanted to
soros has a lot to answer for he's
supporting these people he's supporting
you know progressive da's who have just
clearly gone too far into victimology
i think he's just deeply out of touch
he's very old at this point i don't
think he has
you know a lot of these guys are like
they don't you know i say
this is the edge of the problem and part
of the problem in california is do you
also i'll describe i would describe what
i'm working on to people that i knew and
they'd go
yeah
well that's why i don't go downtown
and you're kind of like yeah but aren't
we like uh what about like the whole
thing about how we're a kind of a single
community in a single country or a
single city or have some whatever
happened to like brotherly love or you
know you are your brother's keeper i
mean that's all gone it's kind of like
or i once after the recall failed
against the current governor i
tweeted out something that was like this
is a problem because we've got this
human rights
crisis on the streets
and somebody responded by putting a
picture of them in their just kind of
douchey little bicycle shorts on a
bicycle like taking a selfie of them
with the golden gate bridge in the
background being like but look at how
beautiful it is and i was like well yeah
my house is nice too but like
712 people died unnecessarily last year
on the streets of san francisco out of
your supposed compassion so pull your
head out of your ass and let's do
something about this as opposed to just
being like i don't go downtown when i
went to sweden several years ago you
know donald trump goes on tv says last
night in sweden and then created this
huge thing so i was like i'll go there
we went to a place called rinkaby
initially everything was like fine we
went to rosengard and they were like
it's dangerous but it was fun
in ring could be in the middle of the
day at lunchtime it was crowded we
actually started getting threats people
were yelling at us and the police told
us we should probably leave the cop said
to me look if if these people start
throwing stones like we can't protect
you and then i was like okay so we'll go
because we we're we had cameras and so
they were yelling stuff fast like
express in they thought we were a news
outlet from sweden because we had a
small camera one of the cameras we use
here actually the same kind
and so one of these other journalists
said oh he's exaggerating it's not
dangerous i'll prove it i'll go there
and so this woman shows up there
goes does not go into the center
shopping area of rinkaby where where we
were stands outside the arches in the
middle of the night wearing a full coat
that covered her hands you couldn't see
the color of her skin you couldn't see
anything about her with her back to the
entrance and said see look i'm here in
the middle of the night and and it's
just that's that's how the media
manipulates and plays these dirty games
to say there's no problem here nothing
to see here the reality was yes a small
blonde woman at two in the morning when
no one's around wearing a coat covering
every inch of her body and not actually
going in
will make a lot of people think there's
no problem because people assume the
middle of the nights when it's dangerous
now the middle of the day is when it was
dangerous when there were 100 plus
people there
and they didn't like the the press and
they took issue with people based on
their skin color
so they'll they'll they'll sweep under
the rug using assumptions tropes and
manipulation oh yeah i mean we've seen
that uh there's basically been an effort
to deny that crime has been increasing
in california over the last 10 or 20
years
we've seen a huge decline in arrests
per reports for shoplifting and so one
of the things they'll say is we'll say
well we were seeing you know fewer
arrests well that doesn't mean there's
less crime we do i got one more question
for you on the subject um real quick
have murders in san francisco gone up or
down they've gone up over the last two
years certainly since the george floyd
protests do you want to know why that's
so substantial
murder rates around the world have been
going down for one reason and do you
know what it is
if you had to guess why would murder
rates be going down
for for the past uh i believe it's about
the past 13 or so years
until now well i mean in the book i
describe um
a variety of factors but i mean the two
big ones i looked at were better
policing and um rising legitimacy
the answer is actually cell phones
the crimes are still being committed but
people have the ability to call ems
within seconds as opposed to before the
era of the ubiquitous smartphone
people would say would see an emergency
and then run to find a phone which
dramatically increased response time so
i actually learned this when i was in
sweden
they were what they were saying was the
progressives were trying to say oh no
look you know like even though uh crime
is going up it's not that much except
when you look at homicide rates in other
countries they were all in a downward
trend
and what we ended up discovering was
since cell phones became something
everyone had when it when it when a
lethal crime was committed or which
which a crime that could be potentially
lethal people immediately called the
police
the ambulance got there within minutes
this decreases the amount of murders
but increases the amount of attempted
murders or aggravated crimes so the
united states we've seen murders going
down in a lot of ways for places where
murders are going up that's in spite of
the fact that people now have the
opportunity to call emergency services
which is exacerbated by the fact when
you defund the police and now calling
gets you nothing
so now we start seeing it go back up
yeah i mean certainly i think there's
it's a it's a it's a complicated
area there's
i tend to side with
two basic strands of research one
showing that declining belief in the
legitimacy of the government and the
system
corresponds with increasing hor
increasing homicides this is all based
on this work from a book called american
homicide by randolph roth
but then i also um you know the growing
consensus among a lot of criminologists
is at the rise in homicides after
ferguson in 2015
and then after the george floyd uh
killing and the black lives matter
protest last summer
was due to basically what we call the
ferguson effect which is the
emboldenment of criminals out of
declining legitimacy but also the
pulling back of police from the kind of
street you know walking the streets
interacting with with the folks
including the folks that are more likely
to come at home thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you